41 seconds of logos by how many millions
do you think FedEx outbid UPS for the
product placement here let's be honest
you can find a hundred different ways to
write a guy onto a deserted island
without it involving a worldwide
shipping leader so this was scripted as
product placement to help fund the film
yes that's right this movie about a man
who spends years on a deserted island
and befriending a volleyball starts with
a box lid view of a package being sent
from a wife in Texas to her cheating
husband in Russia while the intrigue
surrounding this package might make a
great movie we're four minutes in and
all we've seen is a very twisted FedEx
commercial kid runs through barricade
and guard blows his whistle at him which
kind of proves the in efficacy of
whistles if you ask me I took the
liberty to myself okay but why did you
send the package to this restaurant
first so that this kid had to run a mile
to get to you
why not deliver it straight here unless
you just love giving this kid candy bars
and CD player God almost all of this
movies opening is useless wasteful and
makes me angry look at that cheese that
have Ian T that none of that stuff ends
up on the eventually crash plane and
washing ashore to the island along with
the ice skates and the volleyballs
honestly how many minutes of setup did
you need in order to know his life was
fast paced and he was a very successful
smart guy prior to being shipwrecked my
guess is it's way less than 10 and yet
here we are
today's truck was two minutes late the
models would be four minutes late you
know the US man in Russia serious
question does the US Postal Service
deliver mail to Moscow about this doctor
down in Emory in Atlanta it's been a
while since I've seen this movie it's
Stan's wife's cancer responsible for
Chuck's plane crashing on the island
they sure have spent a long time on it
after the previous year's the Green Mile
where he was married to Bonnie Hunt Tom
Hanks decided to date Helen Hunt in this
movie it's the rear back-to-back love
interest game known in Hollywood as the
hump double just in case you have any
doubt about Chuck's adventuring
capabilities here's a bunch of pictures
plaques and books so that assholes like
us won't say how does this ordinary dude
survive on a deserted island damn this
is overkill
looks like they invited home for the
holidays the Family Stone home alone and
National Lampoon's Christmas vacation to
this dinner
holy how do you get a table that size
Christmas I got a gift for you is it
something super on-the-nose thematically
like a watch I hope it's a watch no one
will be seated during the Chuck and
Kelly exchange Christmas gifts before he
gets on a plane and he buried the lede
by not giving her
the engagement ring that he planned to
give her all along Xin Jie's it's almost
like he wants his plane to crash I bet
you forgot that this movie takes a full
goddamn 21 minutes to even begin to cast
anyone away
[Music]
jesus basket-weaving Christ Chuck finds
the airplane seatbelt in under point
zero five seconds an impossibility
that's more impossible than him
surviving this plane crash he's going
after the watch man the power of boners
is stupid okay this crash is pretty
spectacular
it's worth of sin often you know a
better pilot perhaps one played by Tom
Hanks and experienced in water landings
probably could have saved more lives
here like a situation needed more
urgency now the spinning jet engine is
gonna chew him up
rotten Tommy I'm surprised a Megalodon
doesn't eat him before he makes it to
the island not only just Chuck survived
a plane crash into the ocean and this
engine explosion but also survives a
freaking monsoon and this raft good
thing we saw his sailing trophies and a
picture of him on a bike earlier because
I was having my doubts about this until
I remembered that honestly this looks
bad I know but after Forrest Gump Joe
versus the volcano
captain Phillips and Cloud Atlas these
right here are only the fifth roughest
seas Tom Hanks has ever faced look if
you cut out the opening and the ending
of this movie and make it just about his
time on the island I love this movie but
later on he's gonna do the math on how
unlikely it is anyone will find them
because of the size of the search area
and I can't help but apply that same
logic back to the fact that somehow he
managed to drift unconscious onto an
island that appears to be the size of an
amusement park yes yes oosoos pedals are
stymie and Helen Hunt's watch is still
there somehow one of the thing this
movie does extremely well is long takes
often with a stationary camera I mean
how many filmmakers have the balls to do
it doesn't shock like this the answer is
however many directors have worked with
Tom Hanks in his prime and know to trust
him but I'm still removing a sin for the
directorial restraint okay this
motherfucker came in with the time and
is a super trained sailor and knows
better than to draw this message here
but the movie was so desperate for a
tide washes hopeful a sight gag it
temporarily made him stupid I mean just
look at his stupid ass here he knew
enough about tides to put his raft and
the FedEx boxes up on that next tide
free level back there but not enough to
draw this message elsewhere things this
movie either doesn't address or just
utterly glosses over
potable water and how long a person can
go without potable water I mean
seriously you cannot take salt water and
boil it to make it drinkable all this
dudes drinkable water is coming in rain
on leaf variety which we see him do once
or twice in total and how reliably
consistent can that be
my ultimate point is that this movie
seemed to super gloss over the whole
fresh water concern extremely smart
person takes entirely too long to work
through the obvious coconut answer to
his audio riddle look I love Tom Hanks
you love Tom Hanks the whole world loves
Tom Hanks but hearing him shouting to
avoid like Jerry Lewis and the Nutty
Professor really gets on the nerves fast
nothing says FedEx company man like a
guy who just crash-landed into the ocean
and floated to a deserted island on a
raft like I'm gonna pretend like this is
my sorting table and then I'm still on
the clock it's like the realization that
the coconuts are the noise he's been
hearing triggers the first indication
for him that he is both starving and
thirsty as and that's a little weird
he's been more worried about collecting
packages the tide brings in than any of
his human needs the balls on this guy
bringing this many back before even
knowing how he's gonna break into them
wait wait I should have started with the
coconuts on this guy can we do another
tape of all the ways to first attempt to
break open a wild coconut this guy goes
with the Nolan Ryan method goddamn
mother nature did you maybe overdo it on
the coconut security
he seems really surprised to find a cave
on the island he hasn't even begun to
explore prior to now FedEx is now
statistically more reliable at
delivering packages from that plane to
this island but it is delivering I
bought on eBay to my front door movie
yada-yada is over an awful lot of rock
climbing Celia you mean to tell me this
guy didn't carry any cash on him I mean
yeah Jamie's dead though dude love is
great but you can love the asite during
the day don't waste your limited
flashlight on every other second glances
at your girlfriend's picture Jesus
sometimes like you want to dock sigh
this island survival movie that ignores
a lot of the questions I have does
answer the one question we all have yes
he poops and he kicks sand on it like my
orange tabby and what is it about Tom
Hanks and peeing in movies he does this
all the time
Forrest Gump Green Mile a league of
their own Apollo 13 Toy Story the man
must have gotten tired of movies not
addressing whether or not people pee and
decided I'm going to write a terrible
wrong with my acting career again the
movie deliberately showed me a glory
shelf of his sailing accolades so the
idea that he would think this half-assed
without a sail could ever work is just
an excuse to bloat the run time looks
painful like way more painful than not
ever having gone out there on a half
deflated raft in the first place
sorry if I'm having trouble finding my
pity he's drinking that chocolate milk
cave pond water and if you don't vomit
or at least gag a bit you're not human
this is wrong it's out you don't say you
are a jackass
Chuck exposes his gnarly infected leg
which never factors into this movie
again also
this seems to be a legal document but
the middle paragraph of these divorce
papers indicate that the law firm of
mastic and godson is almost like the mom
because it says we have ways and
measures of getting a hold of you
wherever you go I have a feeling they
leave that out in the advertisements
make all the jokes you want to but this
is exactly how Scott Hamilton found his
calling Chuck decides not to open this
one probably as a symbol that even when
things are at their worst he can still
keep some sort of moral compass but man
well if this thing has something he
could really use I don't move 50 sins if
we found out that the box contained a
raft a radio nautical maps signal flares
and add just one drop of water food and
and yes I know that's impossible for a
package the size but what the hell man
like most naked and afraid contestants
eventually a producer came in with a
Zippo and lit dish and then the cameras
started rolling to make it look like he
finally started the fire with this bow
drill free wow what a neat bloody
handprint that could not have happened
when Chuck grabbed this volleyball also
let's not forget Chuck grabbed the ball
with his fingers pointed toward the AVP
letters in this shot but now they point
away from them in this shot could the
ball have rotated when he threw it maybe
but I'm sitting it anyway the Wilson
character ends up being super crucial to
this emotional journey just imagine if
they used another brand like Spaulding
or Rawlings or Moulton or touch acara
just wouldn't have that same sad ring if
hanks were tearfully screaming out
Rawlings good god how can you not take a
sin off for this
look how joy this brings him she's much
prettier in real life
looks like the National Soccer Hall of
Fame enlisted Chuck to draw the image of
Brandi Chastain on her plaque the scene
was cut from the dentist because it was
too graphic I wished the movie I'm
referring to had a more subtle name but
it's the dentist only a lot of time
must've went by like enough time to
shoot what lies beneath also view movie
I don't care all awesome he got it
spearfishing that motherfucker can't
even see this fish from all the way over
there Chuck shows faith in the tape
inside a VHS cassette to keep his raft
intact I know I know
character in a movie he says he's not
gonna do a thing only to be doing that
exact thing in the next shock leash it
also wasn't he making rope out of the
plants on the island so are those
completely gone not entirely sure why he
needs to risk his life for this
particular rope really it just seems
like the movie needed a way to tell us
that he contemplated suicide and didn't
go through with it look the film is just
a few minutes away from the ultimate
Wilson emotional gut punch I honestly
think this faked out Wilson emotional
gut punch under my
it's the real one coming later rather
than adding to or building to it also if
you're on this island and reading this
message haha you're on a deserted island
you I could give you instructions on how
to build a fire but I'd much rather just
tell you how much I love the girlfriend
I left behind whatever Island materially
he used to paint this giant version of
the angel wings doodle he finds so
fascinating and precious they should
damn well have been removed at this
point by saltwater and torrential
downpour he did not have the all-weather
bear collection at his disposal when
painting this it's not an I almost died
at sea movie if there isn't a friendly
whale visit all that storms waves in
this movie is so much of a mother but
what ultimately separates him from
Wilson will be an after-the-fact
harmless wave this movie just made me
cry over a volleyball a volleyball
doesn't that deserve a sit off no no it
doesn't but here's a sin off anyway no
one probably cares about probabilities
at this point except me but the odds of
him being discovered at sea aren't any
better than him being discovered on that
Island sure you're gonna tell me that by
leaving he ended up in a shipping lane
that many cargo ships use and got
himself seen and fine but my reply is
more about how many times he should have
died on that Homer Simpson ramp before
reaching the shipping lane this movie
gives the middle finger to math
basically also we are now done with the
survival portion of the movie in the
final 35 minutes will be about how weird
it is that the mad about you girlfriend
has married mr. big but why what took
for weeks
surely something dramatic and
enthralling happened when that boat
found Chuck and took him back to
civilization why wouldn't we want to see
that we buried you
I had a funeral and a coffin gravestone
you know what I rarely send trailers but
this exact scene was in the fucking
trailer the trailer told you that he was
definitely going to get off the island
sure you knew in your heart he would get
off the island anyway but it just makes
it a little less satisfying to go along
on the journey so you had my funeral and
then you had Mary's you know there it is
folks that's sweet yet sour payoff from
the my wife is dying foreshadowing
earlier on with the Scott I mean this
movie needs all the punches in the gut
it can get right because the baseline
story here is so vanilla I'm Kelly's
husband
she's weak doubt naturally so instead of
coming here herself she sent the guy she
married after you died the why didn't
she send a lawyer or a sibling or a
college friend of all the people to ask
to explain to it you chose your current
as husband
this is very hard night and for everyone
honestly I feel like this movie should
either be trying to explore the crash
survivor island life or the what happens
when I come back from surviving and my
girlfriend married someone else in her
personal impact of such an experience
but not both alas the movie goes for
both this guy on the first day back to
the mainland after four years of Island
survival everyone just leaves him alone
in a hotel room somehow his mental
health was entirely ignored and everyone
just assumes he can process everything
fine and will be up at dawn tomorrow
ready for all the interviews like he's
George Clooney and not someone just
emerging from four years of major trauma
about ten minutes ten minutes with the
girlfriend who thought I was dead for
four years and married while I was gone
should be just enough time for me also I
got to admire this cab driver Chuck is
famous right now and has been through a
lot but he can't spare any time for this
guy
hey man Memphis at this hour is a hotbed
of cab activity right now dude I need to
be free to earn that sweet sweet
weeknight at 1:00 in the morning met
this cab fare thankfully his impulsive
late-night visit to his ex-girlfriend's
house comes at a time when the kids are
asleep and the husband's conveniently
gone and it's raining so she has to
invite him in Houston Oilers are the
Tennessee Titans they went to the Super
Bowl last year they almost won by one
yard one lousy yard right at the end
yeah about that
thanks for crushing my soul again but
the one yard was a chance to get within
one point and then hope something weird
didn't happen with Al Del Greco on the
after point then over time who knows
what would happen to overtime but stop
with the we would have one narrative can
I Drive it car taxi he didn't even wait
the 10 minutes Chuck found the least
sympathetic cab driver in the world
he didn't give two fucks about this dude
it's hilarious and I'm sitting it anyway
because the sin counts probably pretty
low sudden vehicular gift is sudden you
were dead for a long time what a cheap
maybe make up for it a bit I can't give
you my vagina I'm afraid I know that she
told Chuck that this was still his car
but she and her husband have been using
it as a second car now tomorrow mr. big
is gonna wake up and see that the family
has to use one car without being
consulted if Chuck can wait a few months
Kelly will be available again in no time
oh come on he did not see her and
definitely did not hear her in this rain
this kiss while realistic from her
perspective she thought he was dead of
course she still loves him ends up
symbolizing everything I hate about this
movie
which is that his survival becomes all
about his love for her then they neuter
it by giving her a new husband life fine
but this is no longer story deserving of
film treatment he ends up sadist like me
I hate you
[Music]
Chuck likes to play songs that are apt
to the situation and luckily his
favorite artist Elvis Presley did a song
called return to sender which is perfect
for what he's currently doing well it
appears that Betina kept this science
dick off Chuck his little literal
crossroads in his life and I appreciate
the heavy-handed symbolism but dude
seriously go wherever this woman is
going is there even really a choice he
does look in that direction at the end
but he should already be in his car for
the record this is a long ass movie but
it's still shorter than Star Wars the
last Jedi sack is motivated to prove he
can survive the 21 days his overall lack
of experience in an unforgiving tropical
environment may hurt him Zack begins
with a PSR of 6.8 la
87 hours is a shameful outrage this is
just you are a sad strange little man
and you have my pity he died of
dysentery give me the watch I hit this
uncomfortable hunk of metal up my ass
two years
hello anybody oh wow got coral right
there in your leg